die mitte rente ist nicht verhandelbar
[Applaus]
wir werden eine souveränitäts agenda
umsätzen souveränität im
wirtschaftlichen bereich wir wollen die
abhängigkeiten zu einer einzigen region
auf der welt
reduzieren brauchen souveränität bei
sicherheitsfragen
die entlastungen für die mitte der
gesellschaft ist nicht verhandelbar wir
wollen familien stärken deswegen das
ehegattensplitting bleibt erhalten wir
werden die kinder komponente stärken mit
dem kinde splitting und die entlastung
für alleinerziehende ist zwingend
wir werden dieses jahr noch eine neue
regierung sind
[Applaus]